and didn't see all the confetti going
off and you missed all of the uh
celebrations uh then we just weren't
loud enough when we were cheering for
the news that uh Dr John delon's book
building a non-anxious life in week one
is the number one bestselling book in
the United States of America woo yay
that's incredible welld deserved
congrats Dr John delone well I mean and
the team did an incredible job of course
and the platform that you have so
generously given us on top of the
expertise of the team on top of an
amazing life-changing book all of that
culminates into a number one yeah so it
is a great book and the people that get
it their lives will be changed and it's
so it's that's the part that's
gratifying but it also helps to just
come out and win the Super Bowl
occasionally you that never hurts just
Mike drop it right baby just do it you
know so a full number one bestseller
that's John's second number one
bestselling book wow and it came out a
week ago Tuesday and of course the it
takes one week to get get the first date
first sales in data in and um you guys
helped us by pre- purchasing the book a
lot of you thank you for that that helps
a lot to accomplish that goal and uh
it's it's not only an honor but it's
also a big marketing help for the book
and for John for it to land on number
one because when people see a number one
they're like H maybe must be good check
that out it is good it is really
legitimately good so if you U know of
anyone which is everyone that has
anxiety in one way or another uh this
book is for you building a non-anxious
life Dr John deloney number one best
seller in the nation last week boom
that's got to feel good on top of doctor
now he gets number one again yeah well I
mean got two phds two number ones the
guy just loves to do everything twice
there you go there you go two two PhD
overachiever John that's it John that's
it that's you John you're the
overachiever yeah I didn't even think
about that that's good I like that ah so
you can check it out at Ramsey
solutions.com and get it there or
anywhere great books are sold and I'm
building a non-anxious life Dr John
deloney John will be with us to
celebrate but he's out working selling
this book he's out in another city doing
podcasts and uh TV appearances and etc
etc and uh uh which is what we do when
we're out selling a book so um he's out
there hang hanging out in another state
doing that and so we we'll celebrate
with him proper on the air when he's
here next on the air with us but in the
meantime we the news is brand new and we
want to make sure we told all of you
that purchased the book thank you
because it it caused that to happen
thank you thank you for your trust thank
you for your business JT starts this
hour off in Dallas hi JT what's
up hey how's it going Dave what's up
George hey congrats to do Dr joney too
thank you how can we help
today yes so me and my fiance are
preparing to buy a house in Dallas and
basically my my question is I'm kind of
worried if I'm
overspending on my
mortgage and so the house is worth 350
350,000 um I think it's a great deal U
mortgage interest PMI all that good
stuff would be
2840 and our combined income
monthly if we're just could both work in
sales if we're just saying our salary
that's 7,400 if we do our salary plus
50% of commission it's around 12,000
post tax a month okay is this on a
15year
fixed it's not that's the that's the one
yeah I'd put it on 15E fixed or I
wouldn't do it and I think you can
afford to do that and still do it within
these numbers um however you're you're
speaking as if you're already married
and you're not when do you get married
our wedding is is dated for May okay you
do not buy the house prior to
May okay CU you're going to own a house
with someone you're not married
to and so you don't have a combined
income and dude you're talking to
somebody's been doing this 35 years I've
had the horrible stories of we bought
the house together but we didn't make it
to the altar together for whatever
reason yeah and talk about an ugly
breakup or I'll tell you an even
horrible one and this will never happen
to you JT but just to let you know I'm
not just pulling this out of my uh hat
uh the uh uh actually talk to one guy um
he owned a house with his
fiance's mother because she was killed
in a car wreck before the wedding oh and
all of her assets went to her family so
now he's parners with his passed away
horrible trag tragedy fiance's mother in
a home talk about awkward messy don't do
this dude wait on after May you've got
plenty of time in your life to buy a
house you are not required to buy a
house right now and y'all got house
fever you've gone out looking at houses
you've already picked this house out you
might even have this house under
contract do
you I do oh boy it's like he's done this
before I do I'm sorry JT I would not
close on this house I would tell these
folks I'm going to give you my Earnest
May I'm going walk away and and your
fiance is going to look at you like you
have one eye in the center of your head
but um you you know I I am not
predicting a breakup or certainly not
predicting her death I hope none of
those things happen I don't think they
will but you are in no hurry you the
only thing you got in a hurry about is
buying a house you can get in a hurry
about getting
married we where's the urgy we could
solve this you could just go and get
married yeah I mean we could get married
and go to court is there a big is there
a big wedding plan like a huge big deal
there is a wedding plan yeah yeah okay
if you went and got legally married I
I'll bless it I I would say do it but I
I I'm going to beg you not to close on a
home with someone that you don't you are
not legally married to um just because
you're you're leaving all kinds of
potential problems and um and then go
ahead and have the wedding a lot of
people do that these days apparently I
hear more and more I've run into that
more and more that like I'll be sitting
there at a wedding and they'll go know
it's not the real wedding what do you
mean I'm here I drove all the way over
here what do you mean it's not the real
wedding no it's a they got married like
four months ago and this is a dog and
pony show yeah like God who does that
well a lot of people these days I I
don't know this stuff okay so whatever
it's okay old school I'm just I I
thought when you were had a wedding you
got married but I didn't it's a new
thing so it's okay hey if if you do that
JT I would I just don't want you to get
in a a a problem and um you don't and
for those of you that are just shacking
up don't buy a house with your shack up
or whatever you call them okay don't do
that either same problem okay breaking
up is hard to do but if you own a house
together it's freaking impossible well
the fact that JT called after he's
already on contract saying ah here's the
numbers I'm trying to justify it it
tells me he's even going late I don't
feel good about this what do I do yeah I
think your numbers are okay your timing
sucks but yeah everything else is good
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's 3 months free to prioritize your
mental health and be intentional about
finding peace through calming music
prayers meditation and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition if
you don't have a faith tradition this is
a great place to learn more about it
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
8825 5225 royalty is in the house
uh one of the top YouTubers in America
today or in the world for that matter
Graham Stefan has become good friends
with me and uh through George I was good
friends with George long before that
I've been blessed to be on his show a
couple times and he's dropped by here
once before and they were in town so he
and Jack and I just um just did a
version of his iced coffee house and did
I say that right iced coffee hour hour
iced coffee money happy hour be in the
house but there we go yeah so if you
don't know who Graham is you need to
check him out $30
million worth of real estate he has sold
in his life he does a YouTube channel on
finance and on real estate and it's a
lot of fun to check out Graham Stefan be
sure and do that and uh they had last
month they had about 100 million viewers
on all of their various forms of Tik Tok
and everything else and 4 and a half
million subscribers on YouTube so uh if
you don't know who he is it's CU you're
not in that format and that's the only
way it's possible you're not that hip
all all of us who hang out anything
around that know who Graham Stephan is
welcome back thank you so much for
having me back on so good to have you so
first question because you're you you
and I both share this huge love of real
estate and these interest rates ticking
up highly unusual across the landscape
of the last 20 years MH um uh are you
seeing what are you seeing out there
slowdown uh prices what are you seeing
it's definitely slowed down a lot so
what I've noticed a lot of the smart
money it seems to be either buying real
estate and cash or they're waiting on
the sidelines and I think a lot of
people look at real estate from an
investment standpoint and think why
would I buy real estate today making a
six to maybe 7% return When I could use
the same money to buy treasuries without
any work any risk at 5 a half% and there
seems to be a Tipping Point right now
where where deals are very difficult to
come by there's a lot of competition and
sellers are locked in to these very low
mortgages they have very little
incentive to sell if they have a
mortgage that's 4% % why would they sell
and replace that with a seven or 8%
mortgage it doesn't make a lot of sense
yeah cons investors aside consumer to
Consumer seems to be having that
discussion oh absolutely they're saying
yeah I could sell my house the price is
still really good but then I got to go
buy a house at 3x or 4X the interest
rate and yeah I could refinance it later
but they're really not thinking that way
they're thinking uh I'm just going to
wait on this a minute yeah well I think
60% of mortgages right now are locked in
4% or less substantial yes that's almost
all of them you know I mean that's the
am number below 2% is bizarre yeah
that's out there so cool stuff so uh
stock market's doing well yeah like you
said the treasury's there but that's the
little secret everybody in the media the
mass media in particular is talking real
estate and failed to mention that the
S&P in the last 12 months has done about
what 16 18% about that at the peak it
was up almost
20% yeah wow and that's just the S&P I
mean that's just if you just bought an
index fund which people do with their
eyes closed right you don't think that's
that's a no brain no thought thing if
you actually invested and thought about
it and studied a little bit you could do
better than that yeah and Graham I'm
curious a lot of your videos of course
for YouTube we have to be a little
salacious right there has to be a little
Doom and Gloom to get the people to
click but what are your real thoughts
when it comes to the economy what's
going to happen in 2024 where do you
think things are heading are you been
dooming and glooming on your YouTube you
days people don't click though my videos
I like to be pretty unbiased I like to
present the entire picture let people
come to their own conclusions but if you
don't make a somewhat negative title no
one will the videos itself usually are
pretty positive overall but you have to
lean into that because otherwise people
just don't pay attention but you seem
like an optimistic guy you know just
talking to you you are very optimistic
about the future about finances where
the econom is going and you're invested
in the stock market and real estate yeah
well I think you could do well regard
regardless of how the economy does I
think that's a component of it and it
might be a bit short term in terms of
the next few years I have no idea what
could happen everything that I would
think is going to happen turned out
opposite I would have no prediction in
terms of what might happen but I think
long term uh I believe in myself my
ability to make money I think for most
people they have a lot more Direct
Control than they think and you're
betting on the American economy long
term I think so and of course I
diversify I have international exposure
as well but it's a small component but I
do think that's important yeah the the
interesting thing is is that people get
confused between
investing and speculating MH speculating
is a purchase that you're going to turn
fairly quickly it does it's not an evil
word it's just not investing investing
always involves a long-term time Horizon
and when you're investing with a
long-term time Horizon let's call it
five years or more 100% of the time I'm
comfortable with the stock market oh
it's down then get in it's on sale you
know 100% of the time I'm comfortable
with the real estate market well I don't
know five years from now you're going to
not be doing that you're going to be
glad you bought a property you know so a
long-term time Horizon like you said uh
to me it it just Smooths everything out
and change you know then you've got
historical track records and things
start to kick in do I know what it's
going to do between now and this time
next year so I could do a flip no that
would scare the crud out of me that's
why a lot of home builders aren't
building specs right now
yeah they can't you can't you can't
predict it I mean economists and weather
forecasters are the only people can be
wrong half the time and keep their job
right absolutely and then you could be
right once and then claim that forever
you're genius that was my one thing you
could write three books yeah well I'm
curious Graham you're getting married
next year yes it's very exciting this I
didn't know you didn't know this got
congratulations I thought we I thought
you knew about
this break this news no you did not
break new well I'm you were asking Dave
in an interview earlier which little
teaser there about you know his
relationship with his wife Sharon and
marriage is there anything you're
curious about kind of maybe nervous
about when it comes to finances and and
combining those not really Macy and I
are pretty attuned when it comes to
money uh and she's naturally very frugal
like yeah and to some degrees I would
say it's it's a good balance because
I'll certainly go out I don't fret
anymore of like going to dinner and
spending $100 on the bill whereas like 5
years ago that would be like well if I
spend $100 here I could cut back $100
over here and then it balances out and
if I if I skip this over here then I
could I don't do that anymore so i' I've
really come learn to enjoy your money a
little bit yes yeah to I'm still Frugal
but not to the same degree that's when
he got married ah now lighted up a
little bit it lightened up a bit just a
little bit a little bit yeah so you and
Macy are both tightwads and so later
you'll make little tight WS this is
great be this is great A bunch of cheap
skates are to splurge on these days as
you've started to like let go of some of
that and enjoy it a little more I would
say experiences are something that in
the past I would usually foro that to
work more so I would say
experiences uh I would say dinners are
something that I've really been enjoying
and going out to eat a few times a week
and I would say saving time which is
something that I've never really done
spending money for time-saving
conveniences if I could uh like for
instance if I get a nicer seat on the
airplane but that means that maybe I
could work a little bit better if I have
a slightly larger seat I could I could
put my computer in front of me and if I
could get something else done I see that
as as justifiable expense so there's
certain things that I could do to save
time well if you need any tips on
spending ask Dave he's really good at
enjoying his money he loves experiences
he's traveling all over the world so
that's part of it is you know give save
spend you got to have
balance so what's the biggest advice
with you having the one of the largest
YouTube channels on real estate and
money
in in the world today what's the biggest
piece of advice in this current
environment you've got for folks
listening I think it really just depends
on what their objective is I mean my big
thing is always save as much as you can
spend less than what you make I think
those are just important qualities to
have in terms of career though because
that's where I've really gotten the
biggest benefit is just the channel and
the Outreach uh the savings certainly
helped but the income that I made from
that was certainly a big Catalyst but I
truly loved what I do and I still do
it's like to me work never felt like
work it was always something fun and
that's where things came really easy for
me and I feel like if people could find
what they truly love to do where it
doesn't feel like work to them and they
could spend all day doing it that's how
you typically will succeed in areas
where others just can't keep up that's
your unfair Advantage I think you're
more creative you're more energetic and
you have to watch cuz you work all time
this just fun oh yeah it's fun
congratulations we so proud of you and
congrats on the marriage awesome thank
you give Macy our love good stuff Graham
Stefan be sure and check out his shows
on YouTube The Graham Stefan show and
one more time the name of the show I
here coffee hour check out Ramsey on
there I messed it up I didn't want to
mess it up again be sure and check it
out thanks for stopping by my friend so
much this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsay we were using
different systems for for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netweek gave us the
visibility into all of our numbers so
that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us next week
worked for Ramsey and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customer customers
who trust netw Suite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to learn more
get a free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 Gordon is in Flint Michigan hi
Gordon welcome to the ramsy
show thanks for having me sure what's
up well I'm still working I'm 61 soon to
be
62 and was
wondering if I should take my Social
Security at
62 I'm debt free my home's paid
for uh I'm just not sure if I should
wait till I'm
67 I have about
95,000 in my
401k way to go so you're a millionaire
so this doesn't matter it's just just a
mathematical
question correct and it's just I I it's
knowing to do the right thing here's the
here's the way the math here's the way
the math works on the calculation as you
know the sooner you take it like 62
versus 65 the less you get per month for
the rest of your life right correct but
you get it for three years longer or
whatever if you take it at 62 vers 65
you get extra 36 checks that you
wouldn't have gotten okay so there's two
two factors that come into play here one
is the longer you live the more it makes
sense to take it
later because you're going to get a
bigger check the whole
time okay also okay there's the What's
called the present value of money would
you rather have $10,000 today or $10,000
10 years from now I'd rather have it
today and invest it and 10 years from
now it' be $220,000 so the present value
of money so you're getting that money
sooner
and it is more valuable to get it at 62
even though it is less money so if you
took all the money that you in that you
had between 62 and 65 and invested it it
probably would make up the difference
throughout your life mathematically you
see what I'm
saying yes so that the the longer you
live the better off you are to get the
bigger check but uh in other words if
you thought you were going to if you
knew for certain you're going to live to
70 you'd be better off taking 7 years
from or 8 years from 62 to
70 all right but if you were going to
live to 90 you'd have been better off
taking the bigger check from 65 to 90
you follow
me yes so that that's the way we're the
problem is we don't know when we're
going to die and that kind of screws up
the whole formula so no calculator for
that yeah messes up the calculator right
so uh yes the other thing is this um uh
you know I have not started taking it
I'm 63 and I just now thought about it
uh cuz it hadn't mattered um but I
didn't not take it for a reason I just
didn't screw with it because it doesn't
matter but um H I would probably suggest
to do what I haven't I'd probably start
taking it and just throw it in
investment and I haven't done that I
probably need to go do that when I get
off the
air okay I was thinking about just
taking my wife's when she take turn
62 and wait on mind till I'm
67 yeah but the point is let's just say
you died at 65 that'd be a really bad
plan that would be a bad plan yeah
because if you die at 65 and you never
got any Social Security ever because you
were waiting till 67 you would have they
would have kept all your money you
follow
me yes so that's that's the problem with
this thing you can't figure it out so I
I tend to take it early I have a
tendency to take it early even if you
don't need it and turn around and invest
it uh and just leave it alone just
because I don't you know I want to get
something out of these people because
they've been screwing me for 50 years so
I want to get some of it back right
right do you know what the amount is at
62 that you would
get I would get right at
2280 have you calculated it at
65 at 67 it was 31 because I've been on
the social security so it's 900 bucks so
it's $10,000 a year
difference right yeah and so if you
invested uh 2200 which is uh uh 24,000 a
year 25,000 a year okay if you invest
that but for five years it will create
more than $1,000 of income per
month you should take it now and invest
it that's that's why I'm on the phone
because I just needed that reassurance
of cuz I'm still working my company
bought me out two years ago and it was
too soon then to retire yeah this is not
about retirement this is about just when
to take Social Security it's
different yeah yeah yeah so if you're
not going to need that money I'd invest
it I mean even just crunching the
numbers right here 10 years of growth at
10% you'd at 436
Grand at 72 yeah just from the investing
this just investing every single one of
those checks I need to go get this money
I know that's serious Dave what have you
been doing man people taking my advice
and I'm not doing good I got to work on
this like you said you're it's it ain't
worth fiddling with at your level but
well but I yeah it's just it's worth
fiddling with cuz you just anytime you
can stick it to the government you want
to so that I can see Dave going for that
reason it's worth fiddling with Uncle
Sam's been hanging on my money far too
long
oh My Drunk Uncle Sam open phones at
8825 52 everybody's got one in their
family right okay so Anthony's in
Raleigh North Carolina hi Anthony what's
up hey guys uh my wife and I we're on
baby STS four five and six and uh two
years ago we moved from California here
at Raleigh and uh we have some money
sitting in our savings and we just don't
know what to do with it I'm not sure if
we should chunk some at the house or put
some in a 529 for our two kids but it's
about 70k and just looking for some gu
on
this and that's on top of your emergency
fund correct I have 30k in our emergency
fund cool how are the kids doing on the
college
fund uh we haven't started he's two
years old and we have a newborn uh a
baby on the way exciting well there's a
start you can chunk some money into you
know 529 plan and get that thing going
and then use the rest of it towards the
house okay any recommendations on how
much to start off with out of that 70
into 529 well they got so much time it
doesn't really matter all that much just
depends on how heavy you want to do it's
pretty easy to throw 10K on each of them
and you'll be amazed in 18 years what
10K will turn into punch that into a
compound interest calculator and you'll
be like oh okay we're good yeah you you
really got a real strong head start like
you won't have to do much more than that
so I probably throw 10K in each of those
and 50 at the mortgage what's your
mortgage
balance uh
230,000 okay and so you did not come
from California with a huge Equity to
Raleigh and just pay cash for a
house uh no we put about 160 down on
this house here and we have the 70 left
over so that's what this house here is
there another
house no we bought this house for 410 oh
okay you mean when you bought the house
the house here in harali I misunderstood
okay all right so all right so you got
uh two what's your household
income uh 120 good okay yeah so you
throw 50 at this you got 180 left you're
going to be done about four or five
years on the house right that's what I'm
thinking knock this out yeah no question
I'm not letting that sit in the savings
account we're gonna knock on Mr Mortgage
in the mouth I like it great plan get it
get it get after it yeah that's a common
question Dave there's not specific
parameters we put around baby steps five
and six about how much to put in the
college fund versus towards the house
and a lot of people have that do you
have any good parameters around how to
look at that cuz obviously the kids ages
matter yes what kind of college they're
going to go to matters what your
mortgage balances matters yes all of
that matters and and it changes so
dramatically that I've never been able
to come up with an exact formula to go
okay baby step five here's your formula
but 10% yeah it's not it's not because
it doesn't it you know I I don't even
want to pay for my kids's College I
can't factor that in you know Antion um
you know so so the thing is what I have
found though is is that once we get
people on this track and and they're
like him they're thinking about it
they're gen people people don't make
mistakes when they're thinking about it
they make mistakes when they aren't
paying attention and don't bother if I
go deal with college they go deal with
college you know so it works out okay
and that's how baby step 5 has been
successful even though it's super vague
right people come in all the time and
say Dave we put our kids through college
debt free yep they do it we hear it all
the time they figured it out because
they dealt with college this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
if if you're like most people your home
is your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
[Music]
[Applause]
information George camel YouTube Star
Ramsey personality is my co-host check
him out at George keml with a K that
show on remsey networks on YouTube is
blowing up he's having a blast with it
and the listeners viewers are as well
and he's of course the co-host with
Rachel Cruz on Smart money happy hour so
I ran into your smart money happy hour
producer as I was leaving yesterday and
I yelled across the building uh that's
the smart money happy hour producer and
she
went yeah you can't just yell at team
members Dave it frightens them I was
like trying to act like a crazy
or something and it just blew her my
favorite is when your wife Sharon will
text Rachel and I and let us know her
feedback on an episode and it's always
entertaining she loves it yeah she
actually does not do that two other
shows Joe that George that's some it
means the world yeah well it's it's a
dangerous territory because it can that
that knife can cut both ways can I be
truthful it's the only fan I need to
keep the show on the air you're not
going to cancel your wife's favorite
show can't do it yeah but that knife
Cuts both ways that's true
if it ceases to be her favorite show oh
got to keep sharing happy Dave you know
that she's a hard woman I'm just
saying George is also a star of the E
every dollar webinars where we teach
people how to do a budget those have
completely free they are funny and fun
and Jade washaw Rachel Cruz George camel
uh and the every dollar team are hosting
free online budgeting trainings webinars
and teach you how to run the every
dollar app it's all free we'll show you
how to get on a budget show you how to
get on a plan show you how to get tell
your money what to do instead of
wondering where it went and you know
George likes to talk about creating some
margin they go through actual examples
but the cool thing about these webinars
is you can talk back to George and
Rachel and Jade whoever's doing it yeah
we're reacting to the live chat the Q&A
we have people come on audio and ask
their question live like the Ramy show
oh there you go so we're having a good
time with them a modified version of
this all right there we go every
doll.com budgeting uh there's there's
one almost every week um and one of the
personalities you know two or three
times a week is not unusual so be sure
and check them out every dollar.com
bugeting and sign up and be a part of
those all right Justin is in Salt Lake
hi Justin welcome to the Ramsey
Show how's it going guys thank you guys
for taking my call so I am on H baby
step number two of paying off my debt
and I have about $38,000 worth of debt
and I'm 21
so call you guys and see if I can get
some advice on what kind of debt have
you got
situation uh so I got a pass du phone
bill of
$1,900 I got a credit card debt for $700
I got a personal loan out for 1,500 I
got two rep possessions one for 5,000
one for 10,000 I got a current car loan
for 12,000 and I ow my uh girlfriend's
Grandma $7,000 you owe your girlfriend's
dad
grandma grandma $7,000
yeah she helped me uh get down payment
on my new vehicle because my old one
blew a motor on it and I am employed by
her so you're employed by V what do you
do for your girlfriend's
grandmother uh so they do they own a
audio visual company so we rent
equipment in Park City Utah for hotel
sign arkinson Lodge and a couple other
places we do weddings and business
meetings okay so I just go in I just how
have you managed to get two cars repoed
in your 21 years
old uh so when I was 18 I bought my
first got my first auto loan out and it
was for uh 10,000 out lease you made a
bad mistake on that one and the vehicle
had issues and the motor went out and I
said okay guys I'm pay on this anymore
so I let them repossess it so that was a
voluntary repo and then the $10,000 one
was I got into AA accident and remaining
balance on the loan is uh what my
insurance wouldn't
cover because you didn't have enough
coverage that is correct okay well when
I went broke at 28 years old Justin and
lost everything I had a ba two babies
and a marriage Hanging On by a thread I
made the decision I was going to do a
detailed analysis of how stupid I had
been so that I didn't do it
again you seem to be repeating you seem
to be repeating this
pattern so like cars are killing
you oh I've been through 18 cars in the
last four years
so yeah cars are killing you yeah yeah
yeah okay what do you
make uh I make about 37,000 anyway every
year okay are you getting side
jobs uh no I've been picking up a lot of
overtime that with my current job I've
been working 80100 100 hour weeks and
you're making 37,000 doing that yeah
that's just my base without my over my
overtime my overtime wages are about
$3300 every two weeks okay all right so
another 36,000 you're doubling your
income that is that would make sense if
you're working 80 hours instead of 40
okay so that'd be logical okay so um
good all right so you're making like 70
as long as you can continue to get the
OT and if you can't get the OT pick up
something else right yep okay that's
good had a slow season we had a slow
season about November so I got a second
job lined up okay are you paying
payments on the $1900 old phone
bill uh yes I actually uh I'm paying
$300 a month until I get enough to wipe
that one out and I know my credit card L
payment is going to be coming out next
week on Thursday so I be losing that
$600 credit card debt okay the two repos
will settle with you for pennies on the
dollar lump some and so if you have a
$10,000 repo deficit the big one you
probably could offer them $33,000 cash
and they'll take it you're going to have
to argue with them and act like you're
broke and Carry On and whine and I can't
pay it and this is all I can do and
otherwise I'm going to have to file
bankruptcy and you're going to have to
threaten them and all this stuff but you
flop around on the floor and foam at the
mouth a little bit and then they'll you
can eventually get them to settle for
about three
grand okay and same thing on the 5,000
you ought to be able to do that for
about 1,500
bucks get it in writing offer them a
lump sum nothing no payments no payment
plans I can't put you on a payment plan
I don't have room to have another
payment plan I've already got a car
payment that's why this got repoed cuz
I'm a broke guy so but broke guy's 21
years old and I want to settle this I
can give you $3,000 cash or I can give
you nothing and you can get nothing
which do you want do you want nothing I
can do nothing I can hang up the phone
and you'll get nothing what is it you
want and this is how you have to talk to
them because they're brain
damaged okay all right you got to really
lean in dude you got to really lean in
and then get it in writing from them
before you send them any money and do
not allow them to have electronic access
to your checking account cuz they will
take everything in your account
not what you agreed to because they
lie okay okay it's an industry of
scum and so you have to treat it like
you're dealing with pure evil even
though you're the one that didn't pay
your bill but you still have to go treat
them like you're handling an alligator
okay okay and uh so get it in writing No
Electronic access to your checking
account then you can give them a
one-time prepaid debit card number put
the put the amount on there or you can
wire it to them or you can do whatever
but no they do not give them where you
work don't give them your social
security number don't give them your
current address don't give them anything
except
$3,000 and if you want that I'll give it
to you but if you don't I'm gonna let
you talk to a dial tone I got another
repo I can call and talk
to okay and this is how you have to
negotiate hard hard ball and then get
these things out of your life and then
quit borrowing money on
cars yeah that's my uh that's my yeah
never do it again okay yeah no you're 21
and you're already a two-time loser
don't do this
anymore no learn the
lesson yeah what's worse on my situation
my car insurance is like $700 a month on
top of my car payment so that's why you
tickets uh close Okay 91 okay I think we
got to stop you from driving around man
I I think you don't need cars at all
goodness gracious there's nothing in
your life about cars has turned out good
you even got a flan from your
girlfriend's grandmother who's your
employer this sounds like four guns
pointed at your face to me that's a
country lose the girlfriend you lose the
job you lose the car everything could go
wrong if Granny gets pissed here this is
bad oh man let's clean this up man get
it out of your life get this stuff go
make a bunch of money clean these debts
up as soon don't do anything anything
else I don't want to hear about you
going out to eat and you certainly don't
need to see happy hour there's nothing
to be happy about you need to get this
mess cleaned up this is the Ramy
[Music]
show hey it's George camel if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsey Baby Steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started live from the headquarters of
Ramsay Solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing
relationships number one bestselling
author Ken Coleman of the book paycheck
to purpose and host of the Ken Coleman
show uh is my co-host today Ken talks to
folks if you don't know about their
careers their jobs how to make more
money how to love and how to deal how to
love your place and how to deal with
your employer and proper things to do
around the workplace so we're going to
do that and your questions about your
life and your money at 8825
5225 if you haven't heard uh we are all
celebrating around the Ramsey place
right now lots of screaming and confetti
going off we found out a few hours ago
that Dr John delon's second book
building a non-anxious life debuted at
number one number one bestselling book
in America today in the non-fiction
section pretty stink and cool and that's
because a whole bunch of you bought the
book to help folks uh yourself or
someone else deal with anxiety and uh in
a realworld way not in a some kind of
cheesy way not some kind of Egghead way
uh no magic pills but uh the six daily
choices to build a nonanxious life in a
very anxious World congratulations to Dr
John he's on the road doing podcasts and
television and so forth in another city
but uh our congrats to him absolutely
big big big deal and the and the the
street continues for Ramsey Solutions so
we're blessed to be able to help people
in that way so the ab who's up next uh
George George is launch we're launching
a pre-sale on Georgia soon it'll come
out in uh uh January it'll be the launch
date uh but we'll start talking about it
soon like we didn't just now but yeah
anyway that's how that happens so I
actually didn't even mean to do that but
that was well placed I'll have I did
that with Rachel's kids book the other
day I said something on the air and um
then she kind of she like wanted to
announce it on Instagram first so she
was like you you kind of spoiled my
announcement yeah I'm very excited about
that project too because it is it is so
stinking cute I've actually I've
actually read it myself at my desk it's
so well Illustrated and it's so stinking
cute but but full of actual great
knowledge yeah it's a it is a wonderful
kids but a lot of fun so uh it'll be
we'll be talking more about that when
we're supposed to that's right we will
stop talking about it now when when
we're allowed to talk about it that's
right um I just get confused I think I
own the place so it throws throws me off
his name's on the building all right Ron
is in Asheville North Carolina hi Ron
welcome to the Ramsey show thank you so
much for taking my call Dave sure how
can we help uh my father is 84 years old
he five years ago asked me to manage his
finances he's had a stroke he had now
has mild dementia he lives with my wife
and I for the past two years and my
father uh approached me close to a year
ago and offered to pay $10,000 toward my
daughter's College
tuition and then
recently um approached me about getting
a lawn tractor and uh he bought he paid
for nearly half the cost and I have two
siblings who are accusing me of
manipulating him taking advantage of him
and my father almost on a daily basis
expresses his gratitude to my wife and
kids and I that we keep him out of the
nursing home keep him out of his
assisted living and he's very happy
where he's at and he does not pay you
any
rent he does not the only thing that he
contributes is a couple hundred a month
for food expenses uh $25 for his cell
phone expense and then he pays one6 of
the electric cost you know for six
members our household but there's no
rent okay and then so $10,000 and what's
half the lawn director
worth uh he he contributed 5200 toward
it okay so he gave you $155,000 for two
years worth of Care Plus the monthly
bills you told me about and I take him a
doctor's appointment it's taking to
physical therapy twice a week I got that
but you he paid you $155,000 for two
years of care so far right yes yes and
you're prom you're promised no
additional money right correct okay um
and does your dad have money a lot of
money or a little money or what no no he
brings in about 40,000 a year from
Social Security and a pension does he
have a nest
egg no where'd he get the
15,000 uh that he he had saved that up
in his account from his so now he's
broke no he has well he has about 4,000
in his checking account right now but so
he gave you almost all the money he
had for a lawn
tractor
right yeah 5 5200 for a lawn trctor and
then 10,000 for the college
expenses okay well well
um so I guess the what do your brothers
or sisters suggest you do what do they
think the plan is uh they want
transparency on his checking account my
brother is insisting on getting online
access so he can track dad's expenses
and and outflows of money and my dad is
is saying no my dad is very is your dad
still of his right mind with the
dementia he has mild dementia and is he
capable of saying no
legally that's a good question um we've
actually got a doctor's appointment
coming up and I'm going to ask the
doctor you think he's clear minded I
think so okay that's what I'm asking I'm
not asking about the doctor all right
and so um okay so here's the deal um
your dad needs to handle your siblings
not
you right he's still clear-minded it's
still his money he still gets to decide
what he wants to do right it's not their
problem it's not their money so he needs
to call them both and tell them to shut
the hell up okay it's none of their
business right
n right n business okay he's not taking
advantage of me I gave him $115,000 for
these two things that's less than I
would have paid were I in a nursing
homea situation and I've got a much
better living situation I'm very happy
with this Arrangement and it's not any
of your dadgum business shut up that's
your Dad's job he needs to make those
two phone calls and no I'm not giving
you transparency to my stuff has he
given you power of
attorney uh he does has not given me
power of attorney but I am a co- account
holder with honest checking account yeah
well you need to get power of
attorney just for his sake to take care
of him because your brother's an
idiot okay he's a bitter I mean it's not
like you have two he had $2 million and
you went and stole a million and bought
a yacht right it was 15,00
,000 which he would have spent in two
months in a nursing home right and he's
been at your place two
years right and he'll be there two more
years at
least right that's that's that's if you
guys can take care of him as this gets
worse does he have long-term care
insurance he does not um but I'm an RN
by background and um we do have engaged
um paliative care as well so they can
keep an eye on him that way but um I
mean it's a it's a blessing to have him
there we're enjoying our time it's a
blessing that you can do this and except
for the fact that your siblings are all
torqued out about almost no
money right I want I want visibility and
transparency into the $4 that he has oh
brother right what's majoring minors
dude
seriously yeah tell your dad to reparent
those two and tell them to run to go
away
you can't you can't make them stop being
who they are but he can put a b a
boundary up and he should while he's
still of right mind cuz this is not
going to get better it's going to get
worse these people are going to get mad
and mad and madder cuz it's who they are
yuck this is the Ramy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey guys being free to make own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
[Applause]
budget
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
5225 uh recap just a second before we
move on to the next caller um if you are
an
adult and you are are of sound mind
legally meaning you are legally
medically capable of making your own
decisions you are more
morally
spiritually and legally allowed to do
whatever you want to do with your
money you are under no
obligation to share
it with your
ungrateful heroin addict
son there's not a moral or legal o i
half of that money's no half that money
is not yours honey it's his money it's
not
yours if I decide to give you nothing
that's what you get nothing nothing
honey just like the Cheerios right I
remember those that's what you get
nothing
honey it's not your freaking money you
don't have rights to it because you hit
the DNA
Lottery it's not your
money well my grandfather it's not your
money your grandfather he owns his money
if he decides he thinks you're a twerp
and doesn't want to give it to you it's
not your money you get nothing
honey just like the Cheerios keep that
in mind you got no obligation no
entitlement no claim of any kind if
someone's of their right mind if they
leave a will and and cut you out of the
will it's their
money
Tada so some of these people they lay
claim onu before people are dead it's a
little it's a little weird yeah we have
an epidemic of deserve you know it's I
deserve this I deserve that and and it's
just it's a deserve epidemic that's it
it's right next to the dessert epidemic
which I have fallen
pregant well no comment next question
please all right moving on Hamilton New
Jersey Natalie is on the line hi Natalie
how are you
hi I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's
up okay so me and my husband were we
were on baby step 2 for a while and then
we went back to baby step one um ever
since 2019 we like bought a house and
then we ended of getting cars because
our cars were falling apart and um we
were having a baby and all that stuff so
anyway when we bought the house they
said we needed to get a new roof within
the next year or two and that was 2019
so now it's 2023 and we need new roof
and it's going to be like $7,000 and we
don't have anything saved for it and
we're trying to figure out who yeah yeah
like we told you not to buy a house
while you're in debt and you did it
anyway no yeah pretty much I not pretty
much you did me and my husband are on
different we my husband doesn't have the
same mindset as me um so where yeah so
where's his money for the roof he didn't
have it with his mindset does he no yeah
it's not working
no so $7,000 roof is the roof
leaking it's not leaking um it looks
okay so far but have you
got um well not including the mortgage
we have like
109,000 on
what and that is mostly student loans
it's 80,000 in student loans
um 20,000 between our two cars um and
then 5,000 in credit card
and what's your household
income um per month it's about like
9,000 okay so about 120,000 a year after
taxes and everything takeen out
okay I can't help you until you guys
decide you're ready to change your
lives yeah I kind of think you are CU I
kind of hear fear in your voice mhm I
think you're
scared because he he's continue to not
change and you all keep doing the same
stupid butt stuff over and over don't
you yeah and we use we U we budget every
month but it's like every mon
satisfi yeah it doesn't doesn't follow
through no it's a it's a wish it's a
dream you're not you're not really
leaning in the two of you have not sat
down taken each other's hands and look
deeply into each other's eyes and says
nothing happens here till we get this
debt cleaned up we're about to be on
beans and rice rice and beans and we're
going to clean up we're going to quit
buying anything until we get this debt
cleaned up and we're going to live on
nothing and we're going to make every
dollar scream every dollar is going to
behave you all are nowhere near
that yeah you wish you were but you're
not yeah yeah yeah so what what what
what is going to get him moving in the
right direction you have the money to
clean this up once you have the once you
have the
will yeah um I did sit down with him
like actually a couple days ago and I
actually finally listed out like all the
debts that we had and like and and we
you know figured out like okay the de if
we did the debt snowball we'd like pay
it off within like five years just
paying the minimums and doing the de
snowball yeah and so you would be debt
you be you should be debt free in about
two and a half
years yeah if we really if you did what
I teach you to
do you have the money to do it you don't
have the will to do it what did he say
when he saw this pile of dead and his
wife terrified sitting in front of him
yeah we're yeah it's almost like it's
laughable cuz I mean it's not funny but
it's like because we're just like we
knew the student loan debt was bad um
and that's what when you lay it out and
say I can do it in two and a half years
if I would commit to it like an adult
and quit being a child what's
laughable it's not laughable it's very
doable it's not it's very doable why are
why are what's holding you guys up from
doing
that I just I don't know every year
every month it's like I feel like our
gift budget goes is crazy every month
we're like because we have so many
family friends and and weddings and baby
shower has nothing to do with it has
nothing to do with it no I know yeah you
know what it
is the two of you are not working
together you don't agree that you have
to sacrifice deeply for two and a half
years to clean up this mess once you
agree to that the gift budget goes away
we just tell people no I can't do it I'm
broke I'm so broke I can't put a roof on
my own freaking house of course I'm not
buying you a
gift I mean it's real simple did he
resist it when you laid out the the
debts for him what was his reaction you
didn't answer that no no he he was
actually on board he said yeah like that
sounds good but it's just a matter of
like well now we have that but then we
also have to get a roof so how are we
going to afford because we can't wait
you don't have to get roof it's not
leaking it's just looking like it's G to
leak that's right yeah the roof is not
your
problem the problem is you make $9,000 a
month and you keep buying crap you can't
afford like a roof
yeah you can't you need to clean this
mess up and you'll be able to get a roof
you'll be able to get a roof roofs you
can get a roof but the two of you need
to get on a detailed budget together and
deeply sacrifice cut everything out of
your lives no eating out no vacations
certainly no buying anything that's not
necessary to exist scorched Earth
lifestyle and $99,000 a month you can
clean up a lot of debt on that kind of
money
you got a good income but you just
misbehave with it
continuously and you guys are going to
have to fix that when you fix that the
stuff we teach with every dollar
Financial pece University Total Money
Makeover book it works and you'll be
able to do it but you're still not there
that's key folks I hope you heard what
Dave said because we as humans we want
to fit in we want to do whatever it
takes to make everybody happy and the
gifts is not the reason they're in the
holder in but it is the reason why they
haven't decided to make make change yet
they're more willing to be uncomfortable
and deal with with financial Stress and
Anxiety and not being able to to be able
to do this this this this and this
things that don't really matter and
that's what happens you've got to get to
a point where you go none of this other
stuff matters anymore it still matters
too much until you say I've had it which
you've said many times on stage and in
our FPU videos but until you get there
you won't make the change yeah it it's
just it's that way for everybody it's
kind of it's kind I'm I'm kind of smart
I like with her but it's sad it sure is
it's really sad cuz the stress you can
hear it in her voice oh and um and so
that goes away when you get on a
detailed plan and you commit but you
have to reach the point that you don't
care what other people think that's
right the only thing that matters is you
and your husband on one page the kids
don't get a vote your mama don't get a
vote nobody gets a vote and we're
cleaning up this mess we're not buying
anything else until we get this dadgum
mess cleaned up I'm tired of living with
my stomach and my throat I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired when you
reach that point you will do what it
takes to win this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with why refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken colan Ramsey personality is my
co-host today and the Lobby of ramsy
solutions Thomas and Abby are with us
hey guys how are you good hey Dave how
are you better than we deserve good to
have you where do you live we live in
Edmund Oklahoma oh fun welcome to
Nashville how much have you paid off
28,000 good for you and your range or
how long did that take about a little
over four years good and your range of
income during that time uh we started
out about
$330,000 uh had a peak of$ 140,000 and
then we actually are currently sitting
at 90,000 okay all right cool good for
you what do you'all do for a living uh
I'm a teacher and she's uh she actually
got promoted to CFO Chief Financial
Officer or chief chief of family
operations chief of family operations oh
okay all right stay home mom that's why
we're back down to 90 okay I like it
good for you guys so the uh 28,000 what
kind of debt was this oh man that
compris of just about anything you can
think of get my little notes Here got uh
student loans car uh apartment repair uh
credit card and what's the last one oh
our
house way to go weirdos paid for house
you're so weird how what's this house
worth uh we bought it for 175 and it's
currently sitting at about 265 yeah you
paid for yes sir how old are you too I'm
32 and she's 31 31 you have a paid for
house you're so weird none of your
friends have a paid for house no nope
y'all are weird I love you you're
amazing how does that feel to be that
young and not have a house payment or
anything amazing it feels so good just
feels like my grass yeah yeah y take the
shoes off and walk through the backyard
the grass feels different yeah good for
you wow that's amazing so four years
that's that's a that's a long haul uh
was there a moment where you maybe
caught a little extra momentum or you
kind of went from okay we're just
gazelle gazelle gazelle but now we see
the Finish I'm curious what that looked
like um well I think when both of our
careers really took off as teachers um
that's when we were able to really be
like okay like we have income coming in
we can make this happen um military
disability went yeah he gets um military
disability and so we were able to really
have good paycheck coming in every month
to be able to pay that off and just
stick to it yeah and uh we also had a we
got married uh in October and we signed
our mortgage
and then starting in January I started
looking at the like looking at the bills
I was like wow we're in a lot of debt we
got the house we got cars we got credit
card hanging out and I sat down with her
and I made a budget out before she was
really on board with it and I said hey
we can get the car paid off in about 3
months which is about 10,000 bucks yeah
and I don't know for
me I I'm T-Rex arms all the time like I
don't know but um
we I don't know like 3 months in we were
really getting to we like all right we
can pay this off but it's kind of
unrealistic for me but once we got to
that 3-month Mark and we're on that last
car payment I mean that was that was the
okay we can do this like let's keep this
going love I did not marry a crazy man I
thought for a minute I did well that's
still that's still be still out still
jury's still out but yeah W yeah it
change because there's something about
the math that speaks to you and gives
you hope yeah and no one can make your
brain do that but you right and we kind
of kept that momentum going too so after
I sat down and she was like okay show me
this budget thing show me exactly what
you're doing and uh sat down we got
every dollar and really mapped out
everything that we're uh that I was our
my personal goal and we sat and grew as
a couple made it our goals and she said
she was like Hey I I was like I think we
can knock this out make a deal with me
before we like you heard my son in the
back uh before we have babies give me 3
years to pay off as much debt as we can
and she like all right you know baby
fever to the Max and uh sure enough uh
about 3 years after that or about four
years after that brought baby boy into
the world and uh 3 months after he was
born last payment on the mortgage I love
it very cool well it worked out good
stuff man way to go what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
oh man uh teamwork honestly I mean
sticking with each other on through it
um through our weak points I I mean
anytime he was weak I'd be strong
anytime I was weak he would be strong
just reminding each other what the end
goal is and that delayed gratification
that you know this is worth it we can
make this happen so absolutely and for
me anytime that like we were kind of
feeling sorry for ourselves and we just
didn't make that extra payment that we
wanted to I have a what we have a saying
in our house is your effort is bad and
you should feel bad just no excuses yeah
yeah wow that's strong yeah look at you
why got guys what do you tell people the
key to getting out is now at the end of
it that's saying you get working
together all that right yeah just
teamwork and making a budget it's you
have to stick to it you have to have
that delayed gratification if you if you
skip out on anything it's it's going to
be worth nothing so now that the house
and everything is paid off what's the
first big thing you do to enjoy this oh
it was actually yours to uh what did we
do we bought you a couch oh yeah we
bought the couch it's true I mean there
was I really wanted a new couch and when
we we moved in we had this
just ratty gray couch that we got from
did you keep a picture of it oh no we
should have it was in bad enough shape
or we decided we shouldn't sell this we
should just give us away just away
pretty nasty I didn't I I regret that I
didn't keep a picture of the worst
hoopties we drove yeah I've got pictures
of most of my cars from over the years
but I didn't get a picture of the worst
hoopie because I was just so ashamed and
I hated it so bad and I wish I had that
picture that would be a great put up on
on the screen in a seminar you know it'd
be great but now I don't have it oh well
hey and you don't have a picture of the
couch but it's gone and we're on to the
next couch life is good and I got a 46
in TV that was my my little right in
front of the couch everybody's winning I
tell her I want to watch football
looking like this
just like it's
tennis I love it yeah are you
celebrating after the big win over Texas
are you are you involved in that side of
the Rivalry no that yeah oh okay I see
we're we're pokes fans but I mean if
they're playing F you's playing Texas
we'll we'll we'll do a little Boomer
Sooner there you go there you go so fun
well done you guys well done
congratulations very proud of you and uh
you brought your son with you what's his
name yes his name is Troy ah very fun
who was your biggest cheerleader outside
the two of you oh man just our village
uh our family and our friends they were
all rooting for you all rooting for us
nobody making fun of you you thought you
were crazy no I mean now you got a paid
for house yeah yeah they were all very
excited to hear that that's what we
wanted to do and once we made it happen
I mean they were very proud of us so
yeah very cool very cool we've got the
live and give box for you that's the
baby steps millionaires book The Total
Money Makeover book and a Financial
Peace University membership enjoy some
of those give some of those and that's
what that box is for so thank you thank
you for coming all the way to Nashville
you guys are heroes I'm so proud of you
very well well done you've changed that
little Man's family tree and he doesn't
even know it yet your life is going to
be amazing wow in incredible Heroes all
right Thomas and Abby and Troy Oklahoma
City Edmund Oklahoma to uh 28,000 paid
off house and everything in four years
making 30 to 140 to 90 with the CFO
count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're de free
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen getting more and more and more
of these 28 to 32 year olds with a paid
for house it's extraordinary paint the
picture Dave what do you think
statistically is going to happen they
stay on this we're talking millions and
millions of dollars if they save the
house payment from that house from 32 to
62 it's probably right around 10 m
just just the house payment now that's a
phenomenal story just the house payment
just the house payment alert I mean
that's that's just it's it's mindblowing
where they're going to be and most
American young people young couples kids
getting out of college have no idea of
that stat right there that well that
they could have that kind of money if
they would put four years of that's
right you know you know four years of
sacrifice cuz that you know what the
first four years of their marriage I
mean they they cleaned it up they did
house and everything awesome wow this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is
my co-host today thank you for joining
us America open phones at
8825 5225 Lai is with us L's in
Milwaukee Wisconsin hi Lai how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up um so I just started
out listening listening about a month
ago because that is super intimidating
and so a quick question my husband is in
grad school and we have quite a chunk of
debt from it um but he just accepted a
job with a 30 ,000 sign on bonus um that
we'll get next week even though he
doesn't graduate until August of
2024 and so we're not sure how we should
use it and we've kind of come up with
some options the first is to pay for the
next nine months of living in tuition
and not take out any more loans um the
second is to keep it and use it for
moving help or a possible down payment
for a house or three is to just pay off
some of our debt now um to get the
interest down and then take out loans to
pay for the rest of our tuition the
first thing you've got to do to get out
of debt is stop borrowing
more okay so option
one okay and uh so what's his graduate
degree and what's he gonna be doing he's
going to be a nurse
anesthetist fantastic okay and so how
much debt have you got we have 155 right
now okay and that includes his student
loans that is all student loans nothing
else okay good and he's going to be
making what 250
uh 210 starting good good almost like
I've done this before okay and um yeah
so you're you been you currently make
what nothing because you're living on
student loans right right I do Nanny and
so I bring in $1600 a month which just
pays for like utilities and if I if if
what what does it cost you a month to
live right now our rent is 1,400
um so probably I'm trying to add up like
cell phone bills and stuff probably
around like 1,800 a month yeah let's
call it
3,000 okay okay I want you to live on
that when he's making
210 okay and you'll be debt free in a
year and would renting be the best
option right out of graduating you do
not need to buy house you're
broke okay you're in debt up to your
eyeballs you and you don't need to buy a
car and you don't need to go on vacation
you have
$155,000 you make
$210,000 when he passes his bars and
everything and in August goes to work
and the problem with people in that
world is that they make good money he
chose a fabulous career
field and they make good money and they
think that gives them permission to wait
forever to deal with this I'm telling
you to deal with it right now now
yeah and to that end Lor quick question
is there a reason why you aren't working
full-time and making more money than
that um I'm a stay-at home Mom I just
have little little kids at home with me
that's all okay well I got you that's
that's awesome just wanted to make sure
I understood that situation CU we'd love
to see you make more if you could so
40,000 a Year 3,000 a month is 36,000
okay
40,000 from 210 is 17
minus
taxes you can just about pay this off in
a year you can come real close it
probably be 14 months but you're going
to live like you're living now not like
you've been dreaming of living when your
husband has the BigTime job he's a nurse
anesthesist no he's a broke n nurse
anesthesist yeah that's what you need to
think about because all the people
graduating with him are getting ready to
do really stupid things while they still
are sitting on 200k in student loan
debt okay I promise you if you go if you
go with that herd you're gonna go over
the cliff with that
herd right yeah which is why I just
started listening to you because I was
like this is super intimidating and so
didn't know how to tackle it and so what
would our monthly payment look like then
well to try to get that done if you did
155 uh in 10 months it'd be 15,000 a
month right oh my gosh okay that that
just simple math if you do it in 20
months it's going to be 7,000 a month
you're going to do somewhere between
there 12,000 A month's 144 a
year okay and you said try to stay at
3,000 a month for living and everything
what you're spending now why do you need
to go
up true true yeah I mean matter of fact
we increased you said 1,800 I went to
3,000 I almost doubled your
budget that is true I mean it's all
kinds of luxurious compared to where you
now cuz here's the thing once you're
living on 70,000 a year it's really hard
to live on
36 but if you're living on 30 and you
get to live on 36 you feel like you got
a
raise yeah my parents always tell me
don't go backwards once you go forward
it's it's a hard step this is the that's
why this is the time to do it yep
because if you if you kick the can down
the road you go oh we're going to go
ahead and buy a house and we're going to
let this student loan sit over here and
act like it's not a monster in the
closet by the time you do all that and
then you try to cut your lifestyle down
after you've gotten used to the nice
cushy lifestyle it's a lot harder than
it is right now for
you okay cuz right now while you're used
to living on nothing keep living like a
college student right right yeah and I
are little I'm telling you in 14 months
y'all could be free forever think about
it Lori I mean you got the rest of your
life to make $250,000 a year and you
don't have a payment in the world you
know how fast I mean think about it you
could save $100,000 a year for three
years and pay cash for a $300,000 house
that's W so don't when we talked about
putting a little aside for a down
payment ignore that completely and just
do student day yes ignore it completely
you're going to get there my point is
when you have all this money and no
payments in the world you can do
anything you want to do you're going to
be in great shape please do this please
please please will is in Tampa hi Will
how are
you hey Dave how you doing I'm good
thank you for taking my call today sure
what's
up so uh I've done a lot of stupid
things with money for the past probably
five eight years or more um I finally
got ahead and and I've been listening to
your podcast I'm in the FPU as well for
the past month so me and my wife we we
did uh week one and week two um and one
of my biggest worries right now is to
you know create a nice uh fun fund for
college for my kids I have a kid that's
12 and another one that's nine and I
kind of worry about you know how can I
create that fun while you know paying
for debt and all that you can't you're
going to do it in baby steps remember
you remember the baby
steps yeah but the thing is my wife
doesn't trust
me the baby steps you you call and ask
me how to take care of college get out
of debt first follow the baby steps
you're in Financial Peace University for
God's sakes
yeah but she my daughter is 12 I mean I
probably you think it's gonna take eight
years to do
this I don't know the way that I'm going
well the way you're going suck that's
why you're an
FPU so what do you
make uh I make about 95 a year and with
bonuses it can get up to 130 cool you
got a great income what's your how much
debt have you got not counting your
house uh not counting my house I have 43
in my student loan um 16 in my wife and
29 in in her car okay well she's going
to hate this even
more I know she does we've been you know
coming back and for about the car I want
to sell it want to
yeah $330,000 car and yall are broke
people it
does so is she going to financial P
University with you
she is are the two of you doing a budget
together we are okay are thing the
question you guys need to sit down ask
yourself is not do do I want pain
tomorrow the question is do I want pain
10 years from
now how long y'all been
married uh it's going to be 15 years
next year how long you been making six
figures uh about since 2016 yeah can you
not look at each other and say it's time
for a change you make $100,000 a year
and you're
broke mhm for almost a decade y'all need
to change something don't
you yeah biggest problem was that I no
the problem is the two of you have got
to look each other and say it's time for
a change and that means we're going to
do whatever it takes so that the 10 year
from now version of me likes the current
version of me cuz you don't like the
2016 version of you cuz he's been stupid
for eight years
and I've been stupid I know what stupid
looks like I'm not picking on you but
you guys are y'all are broke and you
make $130,000 a year it's time to change
something man you can't keep doing the
same thing over and over and expect a
different result this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey it's Ken if you love the show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the ramsy way go
to ramsy solutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's ramseys
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Ken Coleman number one bestselling
author and host of the Ken Coleman show
Ramsey personality talking about career
jobs and having uh fulfillment in that
area of your life also making more money
than you ever made in that area of your
life it's a good idea he's my co-host
today as we take your calls about your
life and your money our congratulations
we learned a few hours ago that Dr John
deloney has his second number one
best-selling book building a non anxious
life debuts at number one in the nation
on the non-fiction list way to go Dr
John John delon's in another city right
now doing uh media and uh podcasts and
such for this book as a matter of fact
to continue to promote it but uh so
we'll have an official celebration on
the air with him when he gets back next
week but in the meantime um a few hours
old is that information that we just
found out he's number one in the nation
very cool quite a milestone that's his
second number one very very good stuff
he and Rachel will also be doing the
money and marriage event uh coming up
October 19th through the 21st and so
we're talking seven days from today and
there is still a few tickets left it's
here on the Ramsey campus it is a
weekend long very intense very hilarious
because the two of them oh my God
they're standup comedy and um I mean
just walking around with them they're
that but you put them on stage it's even
worse so you're going to laugh you're
going to cry you're going to learn about
marriage you're going to learn about
money uh bring your spouse obviously
it's a mar a couple's weekend and it's
here on the Ramsey campus you're going
to have we're going to treat you like
kings and queens you're going to have a
blast and you're going to learn a bunch
there are a few tickets left if you'd
like to come that's why I'm mentioning
it it's $7.99 for this multi-day event
and uh just a few hundred people it's a
small event very intimate you'll be able
to ask a lot of questions have a lot of
interaction with John and with Rachel
Ramsey salute solutions.com
events and um make your way over here in
about a week and hang out with a couple
of number one bestselling authors
that'll help you do all that stuff
Lindsay is in Washington DC hi Lindsay
welcome to the ramsy
show hi thanks for having me on sure
what's
up I have a rental property in
Washington DC and I'm trying to decide
if I should pay off the mortgage and
keep it as a rental or sell it when my
tenants lease is up I'm currently debt
free and I'm not ready to settle in one
area so I'm renting as my primary
residence but currently my rental income
covers the mortgage and the condo fees
but I'm paying a property manager out of
pocket should I continue paying those
out of pocket expenses and put all my
extra income and my rsus towards paying
down the mortgage you have the money to
pay off the mortgage now or not no but I
could pay it off in probably the next
like seven years is what I've calc stay
there but it's a it's a rental property
right now I know but you're not going to
stay there you don't want long-distance
rental
properties you don't want you don't want
a rental property in Washington DC and
you live in Dallas that's a bad plan
you're going to end up with a
mess so I I own a bunch of rental
property I don't do long-distance
landlording bad idea that's how people
end up changing their Harley in your
living Harley Oil in their living room
so um I know you've got a property
manager but there's no property manager
like the person that owns it so you got
you're always looking at it you're
thinking about it the property manager
is not shame
uh I don't know I mean the property
manager for the past few years has been
really like it's been an amazing setup
my only like qualm is that I'm because
my condo fees keep going up little by
little it like I'm I'm closing the Gap
to cash flowing but I'm I have not yet
cash flowed
it what could you make if you sold it
today um I could probably make like
profit like
$50,000 yeah okay this condo is not a
financial blessing to you it's an
alligator it eats it doesn't
feed so you're feeding you're feeding it
I don't want it I want something that
creates money not takes
it so did you used to live in
it I I did yeah yeah okay you became a
landlord by default not by plan cuz very
few people would sign up for the plan
you've got it's not that much
fun cuz you're not making any money
you're paying
money I was in the military and a lot of
them like the the going advice in the
military was like buy property
everywhere you go yeah going advice to
the military is wrong we work with the
military all the time that's a dumb idea
you'll end up with a condo in every city
you ever stationed in oh my Lord talk
about a bad idea let's have a rental
property portfolio scattered all over
America
yeah no I'll pass I would sell it you
don't make any money on it it's no
there's no there's no Financial fund it
won't even buy you dinner I mean it's
not you know you just pay for it all the
time no I don't I don't want that I
wouldn't have a piece of property I lost
money on all the time I had one and I
was sitting and waiting on it to get
better oh not because it was a it wasn't
rented it was a big old office building
that was a shell kind of thing downtown
Nashville I bought it at a deal and I
sold it for a couple million dollar
profit over what paid for it but it was
sitting there eating taxes and eating
insurance and eating everything cuz we
didn't have any tennis in it cuz it was
a shell we were going to build it out
and I finally just went this is dumb and
I just sold it I'm going to put a couple
million in my pocket and forget it why
am I I don't want things I have to feed
yeah they're supposed to feed me I'm not
supposed to feed them that's not how
this works so yeah get rid of it that's
what I would do parents all over America
are questioning having teenagers
now that they might feed you later you
know that's no that's not what he meant
but I I couldn't resist yeah that's
there that's true that's my reality
right now you're sitting there talking
about that and I'm going I got a bubble
above my head I have a mortgage payment
that is called my food bill yeah I have
two teenage boys that eat a lot oh oh
yeah yeah yeah a lot yeah these are
these are
IG humans big humans that's right love
it Rainey is with us Rainey is in
Orlando hi Rainey how are
you I'm doing good how are you great how
can we help
so I recently quit my job stupidly
without having another one lined up and
I wanted to know is it worth it to take
a lowp paying temporary job versus doing
side jobs like delivering food or
packages or something like
that why' you do that yeah
what um a lot happened and it was really
draining my mental health and we
discussed it multiple times and nothing
ever got better and then I just just
kind of got to my breaking point that
day okay so let's let's let's look at
your question so have you run the
numbers can you give me numbers on the
low paying job versus these uh what
you're calling delivery or side gigs
what's the difference that you've
figured out that you can make between
the
two so it kind of definitely varies um
we do have some debt and bills that we
have to pay I've been offered jobs that
only pay $12 an hour versus doing like
delivering food which I have opportunity
to make tips and stuff which I feel like
could make more but it's kind of up in
the air cuz it's per delivery all right
so here's the thing we can't feel
anything right now you need your income
it doesn't seem like it's an option so
you're taking the best pain job or jobs
to get back to what you were making in
your salary job while you're busting it
to get your mental health in a situation
where you can get back into a full-time
role there's no option here you've got
to make as much money as possible to get
back to where you were $12 in this
market is absurd yeah every being's
playing 20 yeah don't take a $12 job
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host to the today our question of the
day is sponsored by neighborly your hub
for Home Services if you're moving you
have a long list of to-dos but
neighborly has local Pros like
housemaster five-star painting window
Genie and and Junk King to check items
off that list download neighborly the
app to find and schedule Home Service
Experts near you it's a great company
yeah it really is today's question comes
from Tara in South Carolina I'm 49 years
old a single mom of an 8-year-old and
I'm debt-free including my home I've
always been risk averse and an
aggressive saver before I discovered
your program I was planning to have my
home paid off by September 2024 but went
ahead and pushed through and paid it off
in August 2023 I have n worth of
approximately 1.5 million and have an
established college fund for my daughter
which I continue to contribute to
however I feel unsettled about what's
next I've always been working to pay off
something I feel like maybe I should be
saving up for a retirement home or
making some other Financial move or
maybe I'm just not used to being still
and not hustling so hard am I crazy well
Tara no you are not crazy you are a hero
as a single mom uh you so much going on
what you have done done is unbelievable
I think this is just a function of
you've been going so hard so long it's
kind of like the runner's high uh where
people they get in that they get that
another gear the body and everything's
moving you're used to that pace and then
you come off of that and you kind of
crave it you want to get that again and
I think you need to be still for a
little bit rest uh relax reward yourself
for what you have done you've earned it
and then instead of the hustle to pay
something off uh I love mov moving into
a different gear not quite as intense
instead of fifth gear maybe how about
fourth gear of of investing towards
something that you care deeply about
giving some of your money your time to
causes that you care deeply about I
think that's a great downshift and
there's just no way you're ever going to
just be still so I'm not worried about
her yeah 49-year-old single mom worth a
million and a half wow um that's pretty
cool including including a paid for
house yeah you're in really good shape
and so yeah do hit the next stage
there's nothing left to do but baby step
seven we say baby step seven is build
wealth and give and so continue to build
set yourself some investment goals but
as Ken said you can dial back the
intensity of a couple notches and set
yourself some crazy generosity goals um
one of the things we did as we started
hitting the early stages of baby step
seven was we had a goal okay I want to
give away more than we made one year
yeah that was fun you know or or more
than we made our first year or something
like that you know may maybe when you
were if you're 49 maybe when you were 29
what was your income that's my
generosity goal and on top of my tithe
I'm a Evangelical Christian so I give a
tenth to my church but then other than
that what what other generosity can we
come up with is fun and different and
you'll end up enjoying the investing and
enjoying the generosity and it won't be
this the
Haggard desperate sense that pace that
you've been running on um you know pain
and pleasure are both motivators now
you're on the pleasure motivated side
you've been running in desperation away
from all the stuff for a long time and
and that's the pl the pain side but I
know I know the feeling and then you go
oh that's so much fun I want to do that
again that's the pleasure motivating
side and that could be a travel thing be
something you do with the 8-year-old it
could be something you buy it could be
an investment it could be generosity you
know you find I'm going to fund XYZ
something I never thought I could do
you know and wow it's fun to watch that
happen Virginia's in Durham North
Carolina hi Virginia welcome to the
Ramsey
show thank you good
afternoon I am 66 I have no spouse no
children and I'm doing some estate
planning it is likely that it will be a
niece or a nephew that will handle the
details of my
funeral I've talked to a funeral
home and to get some estimates and
they're telling me that they will
require payment before they render any
services and uh that they won't wait for
probate so they can be paid out of my
estate so I'm looking for ways to put
money aside so that my family can get to
it quickly without having to pay for it
out of their pocket first and then get
reimbursed from the estate yeah you can
have a a pod a paid on death account in
Most states just a just a regular
savings account you can have a s a
savings account or a checking account
that says paid on death pod ask your
Bank of North Carolina does that I'm
pretty sure they do most states do and
um and that just simply means it's not a
probate issue that the money's just paid
out to them at death they can go over
they go over the bank and pick up the
money and then go to the funeral
home okay just like that are you going
to pre-plan the funeral home I'm going
to pre pre-plan probably but not prepay
good that's what we advise and so if
you've already got the budget done then
you know how much to put in the account
right right by sitting down with them
okay I've already got all the selections
done all they've got to do and then they
don't have to go over there and make any
decisions they've just got to go over
there and punch the
ticket right because you pre-made all
the decisions that's very wise and um
let me tell you funeral homes uh often
tell you what they told you but they
also often will work with a family in a
real situation the reason they tell you
that is they'd like for you to
prepay that's why they push you on that
and I don't like for you to prepay I
like for you to pay when you die that's
I don't don't need the funeral till I'm
gone and me meantime the money can sit
in a savings account put it in a highly
yield savings account let it earn four
or five% to sitting in their bank
account okay yeah okay you're very
you're very wise you're very kind to
your family that's very diligent of you
well I'm not really close to any of my
nieces or nephews and so I'm trying to
make it as easy for them as possible
somebody's gonna have to do
it yeah I made it easy screw up
generation sir they'll be gone everybody
else will be
gone good for you all right that's fun
and you know you could have just a
friend that does it too if you'd prefer
but um you know however you want but pod
account and you don't need to put as
just the right amount in there to cover
the funeral that's all you need to do
and if it's a tiny bit off believe me
the funeral home will work with them
it's not they're not quite as hardcore
as they like to come across yep Peter is
in New York City hi Peter welcome to the
ramsy
show Hi how are you guys thanks for
having me sure what's
up um so we're on baby step 2 my wife
and I we're both 28 um we have a child
we're planning to have a second child
sometime in
2025 um and uh currently we have about
$225,000 in savings and we're looking to
um we're thinking about saving some of
that money you know not going down to a
th um in order for when my wife goes um
uh on fraternity leave um that weay
she's not
pregnant no not yet okay we don't do
that no you need to get out of debt how
much debt have you
got um we have about 927 th000 total
debt that includes your
mortgage yes we have two mortgages yeah
I'm not counting your mortgage how much
debt have you got honey uh 63,000
roughly and what's your household
income about 198,000 gross okay so if I
woke up in your shoes I'd put 24,000 on
the 63 today and I'd be debt-free before
probably probably Christmas oh my God
you make so much money pay off this debt
qu screwing around with this little
debt you know you're act you're acting
like you're going to keep this debt
around like it's a pet it's you make
$200,000 a year it's 63 Grand you
already got 25 of it how fast can you
come up with 40 and about three
heartbeats quit spending
everything with with our expenses um
yeah I know you got really expenses you
live high on the hog that's what we call
it in Tennessee not New York but yeah no
I'm actually European I'm from Croatia
that is not a thing in Europe especially
not in Catia which is a former
Yugoslavian country when it's separated
people Didn't Trust Banks so my parents
really weren't into that the only thing
they got was a mortgage and that was a
seven-year mortgage you have a fabulous
income take some of your huge lifestyle
and turn it back and clean your
wonderful debt up so that when your wife
gets pregnant you got money in the bank
and you have no debt except your
mortgage that's where I would be if I
were you
Peter that's very doable with the math
you gave me once you make the decision
your ways from making the decision based
on your sentence structure this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions all on
the debt free stage David and Tammy are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you Dave better than I deserve
welcome how much have you paid off well
$442,500
43,000 very good way to go guys and how
long did this take you about 12 years
okay and your range of income during
that time we started out about 110,000
uh this year we're on pce to be at 360
cool what do you'all do for a living
well I'm a product strategy manager for
the world's largest just construction
and mining equipment company mhm uh and
I'm a technical writer I specialize in
proposal work um and I moved into
business development about two years ago
so oh very good that was a smart move I
like that very good both of you you're
killing it excellent job where do y'all
live Pur Illinois oh fun what kind of
debt was the
443 about 138 of it was credit card
normal debt right car boat loan uh
things like that M and then this March
uh we paid off our
[Music]
mortgage looking at weird people yeah
what's this house worth about 350 love
it how much in your retirement accounts
um about
1.5 love it did you guys inherit any of
this money or are you baby steps
millionaires um we were baby steps
millionaires but my parents passed away
a couple years ago and did leave us a
nice gift okay but prior of that you
were already millionaires way to go you
guys so proud of you look at you man how
that's so fun from the ground up baby
how long y'all been married 28 years 28
years so what happened 12 years ago put
you on this ramsy stuff tell us the
story well um about 2009 I guess um we
had a you know kind of a blip in our
employment and I sat down and we read
your book he had heard about it from
work um and I did a spreadsheet and
honestly Dave I cried I cried cuz it was
so bad um we had so much money
going out and not nearly enough coming
in um we were making pretty good income
um but it was just all going to dumb
stuff honestly um we just weren't we
weren't paying attention to where it was
going and we weren't naming our dollars
and um they were getting away from us so
it was a problem yeah and and then once
you guys decide to attack it I mean
you've got the skill set I mean your
technical rer Business Development and
he's in project management this is like
the ultimate project management process
right exactly just going to okay let's
whip this thing yep that's exactly what
we did and you just lean in and boom how
long before you got rid of the uh
Consumer Debt it was about 23 months and
then we went out and did bought a new
house M following your principles and
guidelines we needed a house with a
little bit of land uh to put up a bigger
garage I still have the first car I ever
bought and very nice part of our
celebration um after we paid off the
house was to start restoring that car ah
what is it 1979 Trans Am nice yeah is it
black with a bird on the it is not black
no it's got the bird on it it does have
a bird on the bird on it oh my God it's
in restoration field right now and we
were able to buy two more for him now
that we've paid off all our debt so we
now have a garage with with fun cars two
more transs yes I have three total oh we
we have three we
three there a slip yeah he's he's an
awesome mechanic and um it's really cool
to watch him build him back so that's so
fun very cool what are the other two
uh 1992 Trans Am convertible and 2001
Trans Am WS6 I don't even know they're
make I mean I'm I'm from the 70s so yeah
they quit making them in 2002 okay all
right that's the last one yes okay wow
all right oh man amazing well I guess
pontiac's gone really isn't it yes it is
so there you go oh my gosh wow that's
cool that's a classic that's the uh the
uh uh smoking the Bandit smoking theand
B Reynolds yeah that's it the black one
would be he didn't know the black one
all right so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you pay
off everything house and mortgage and
build a $1.5 million net worth in uh 12
years that's pretty impressive well Dave
just slight correction almost $2 million
net worth oh I'm sorry the one and a
half was just savings just savings oh
yeah you're right okay plus
one yeah um yeah so really for us it was
just getting on the plan naming every
dollar um having budget meetings um
spreadsheets as you can imagine as we
start started out and and just naming
every dollar where it went our friends
think we're so weird cuz we had
Financial meetings every month where we
sat down and said okay how's it working
and then once a year we get together and
say okay you know do we need to bump up
this budget here or do we need to move
this down um like groceries you know
have gone up so we're like well we
should probably put a couple hundred
dolls more in groceries this year and
they're like you're so weird
but you're not yeah but you're not broke
and they are oh my gosh yeah they sit
down to a spreadsheet and cry and you
don't anymore right oh my goodness way
to go you guys way to go I'm so proud of
you were people outside cheering you on
or did anybody know you were doing this
um several people did know we were doing
it we had family and friends cheering us
on um you know everybody would call me
cheap or
Frugal um if it's not in the budget
doesn't doesn't get spent right
especially if it's a a discretionary
purchase right that's how a project
works exactly you execute on the project
I love it that's great that's so great
very cool good for y'all good for you're
Heroes man I mean you did it we did do
it how old are y'all I'm 52 and I'll let
her tell her age I'm 53 okay um so you
know we're we're feeling like we're
we're ready to you know retire I mean I
I couldn't believe we would be here yeah
um where we started so it's it's just
really cool and you know we have family
members now who are following and have
gone through financial peace and I think
this will change their lives as well as
it changed Stars oh yeah well when he
got the third transm I thought maybe he
would knew what he was doing you know
it's like that's they had nothing to do
with anything else it's like he keeps
buying cars he must be okay you know I
like it yeah I can hear family now
that's just fabulous well done very well
done you guys well you fit the mold you
fit the template from the uh from the
millionaire research study that we did
typical millionaire is 52 so you're
right on it and that's uh uh it didn't
you you were there a long time ago so uh
but the of the ones that we studied we
found that that number 49 52 38 now we
found a bunch of young ones too and we
found some old ones but that's the
you're right in the perfect in the
median right there that's a perfect hit
good job you guys great job so what's
the first big thing you're going to do
other than buy cars to celebrate well
we're going on a cruise here uh next
month where you going uh just a short
one through the Bahamas and just getting
warmer weather being from Illinois you
know it's fall it's starting to get a
little cool yeah why not we laugh
because uh when we um we paid off the
house we both got on a conference call
you know and sat down with the bank and
they said okay it's paid off and we're
like okay like that's it so we went back
to work so we tell everybody we just
went back to work after so no steak
dinner no nice dinner that no we exactly
went back to work we were busy so
no I love that you were serious serious
individuals all right there's more to do
we have a plan for pretty much
everything I'll bet it's so good hey
real quick uh because of that are you
beginning to plan about some kind of big
Vision that's that's out there you guys
are still very young 52 53 what's what's
what's that plan yeah so our retirement
goal is we we mentioned we own a boat so
our retirement goal is to do the
America's Great Loop oh yeah that's a
great that's awesome got sailboat or a
yacht we have a yacht okay good very
good so we are building our way towards
that goal when we retire do you need a
cabin
boy you know we
take up room and he doesn't eat much I
don't we have several nieces and nephews
whove already volunteered he's fairly
he's fairly needy emotionally
though takes one and0
one that's a great plan you that's a
great I want to do that Loop one of
these days I never thought of that I
need to I know several people done
that's one that's one I would do I need
to put that on the list I never put it
on there we might see you out there yeah
absolutely hey we've got the liveing
give box for you baby steps
Millionaire's book which is you and The
Total Money Makeover book which is you
and the Financial Peace University
membership which is you so apparently
you will be giving all that away but
we'll give it to you and let you give it
to who you wish and uh you may enjoy the
book or who knows great stuff you guys
I'm so proud of you David and Tammy
Peoria Illinois 52 baby steps
millionaires
1.85 paid for house and everything
$443,000 paid off mortgage and
everything in 12 years making 110 to 360
count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb
free yes they are
wo yeah I love it this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
yeah
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're with us our
scripture of the day is proverbs
28:19 whoever works his land will have
plenty of bread but he who follows
worthless Pursuits will have plenty of
poverty Sam eing says hard work
spotlights the character of people some
turn up their sleeves some turn up their
noses some don't turn
up that's a great quote I've never heard
that I haven't either some don't turn up
at all some just don't turn up you got
to love it Eric is in Canada hi Eric
Eric welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi hi there um thank you for eron I
called you Eric I'm
sorry it's okay um I recently found the
Ramsay show and enjoyed listening to it
even from Canada where I have to
mentally juggle the differences between
Canada and US Financial products sure
and I apologize in advance if I sound
confused I kind of am I'm really just
looking for direction on what to do to
get a better sense of how my husband and
I are doing and what we should do next
but I think it's really just kind of to
get on the same page um as a new
listener I'm familiar with the baby
steps and I think that we're on four and
five um we both have my husband and I
both have jobs that we enjoy with
healthy salaries and index government
pensions we own our own house with a
mortgage that has considerable Equity we
have a rental house with a mortgage with
considerable Equity that's profitable
after tax we both have emergency funds
and we have um funds started for
Education funds for our children and in
addition to the work pension we both pay
into registered um our R rsps which is
Canada's version of a re retirement um
registered retirement account with
automatic transfer um but despite all
that I feel like we're living paycheck
to paycheck and I'm always confused that
a family with a gross annual income of
over 250,000 it feels like we're just
getting by and I don't know if it's
because like how we're managing our
money or if just because you live in a
very expensive area in Vancouver um but
my husband and I have been together for
14 years and married for nine and we've
always sort of kept our finances
separate and that's because we bought
our first house that's now our rental um
when we weren't married and um I know
it's not recommended from what I've
heard but we've kind of kept our
accounts separate and just combined a
couple that we really needed to get by
um but I'm really just looking and I I
think the next step is to kind of just
get back on the same page and um create
a plan for us and start doing monthly
meetings but I don't know how to start
that process and um I've always kind of
been the family CFO and uh I just need
to get like a better sense on how to
bring this up to him and some practical
steps on how to get on the same page for
the first time okay all right lot going
on here um thanks for the
outline
um I'm trying to figure out like you the
core of this is when we do whatever it
is you're going to do combining finances
or any other moves that you make the net
result needs to be that you get some
peace because there's a lot of strife
and struggle
and scratching and clawing in this isn't
there well you know it's like I don't
know I don't know why we can't live on
250,000 and feel like we're not broke
you
said it is it's as we look around and
we're like I feel like that's healthy
and and we see friends doing well and
you know I just always think like I wish
I could see what someone's bank account
looked like no you can't CU most of them
most of them are not being nearly as
smart as you are you've got your stuff
dialed in most of them are just living
you have no idea how screwed up they are
their life looks good it looks like it
looks good for a second on Instagram but
if you really got on the hood and make
you puke um yeah yeah so that's what I
tell my hus that's what I told my
husband that's exactly right I promise
you I pull up at a stoplight I see a
nice car now I don't see a nice car I
see payments MH
yeah that fool's got a $1,250 payment
that's what runs through my head um I
used to see a nice car now I see a fool
but um the uh um anyway the yeah I I
think you need to sit down with him and
say Hey you know we've done it this way
14 years it's passable but I feel like
I'm holding this together I feel like I
got all 10 fingers stuck in the Dy and
it's I'm and it still feels like water's
getting over me and I really want to
combine these things so it I don't mind
doing the execution of our plan but I'm
tired of developing the plan by
myself and I want us to combine things
and you and I make a a group of basic
decisions on what we're going to do with
our money lay out a budget each month uh
where we know where every dollar is
going to go we both agree to it and then
I'll do the execution I doubt he wants
to or would relish taking over the
Tactical paying of the bills which you
kind of actually enjoy probably
uh I I think I like having control of it
um yeah and I think that there's like a
level of trust too or like I I would I
would worry about relinquishing that and
I think that that's why I've always kind
of want relinquishing the
trust or relinquishing the power sorry
that's fair of of you know knowing it
all but with the power comes the
stress yeah and that's probably what's
putting the strain on you that's what
I'm saying I I'm I listen I'm I'm
America's Financial nerd right so don't
you know I do this stuff and I and I you
know my opinion between Sharon and I
carries a lot of weight uh but we don't
do anything unless she's in alignment
first and then that helps me because
we're emotionally carrying the decisions
of our giving emotionally carrying the
decisions of our investing or our big
decisions together and then I'll go do
the execution of it it's it becomes a
no-brainer and that also prevents I told
you so
um I knew you were G to screw that up
you know well Shar Sharon could tell say
I told you so it could happen at my
house and it doesn't happen cuz she
can't she was in on it you know if
something screws up it's like we screwed
that up not like I I knew you were going
to mess that up you know that doesn't
come up at my house hasn't in 30 years
so it's really nice I like it so um I
got a question Erin because I'm
listening to this back and forth here
and you you said that you that I thought
I heard you say that you and your
husband both have a emergency funds is
that
correct yeah is that three to six months
on each side between the two of you uh
no not each side combined together it
would be that but um okay when I think
if we both lost our job at the same time
that would not be great but and you're
both investing or you're com you're both
investing 15% or you're combining
investing 15 no we both we both have um
government funded pensions do you have
any other debt besides the
mortgages no none yeah I think it'd be
really cool to dream together again too
to dream together in high definition
about okay we can if if we could find
some money in this $250,000 budget what
would be fun for us to do what investing
would we do would we pay off the house
would we pay off the rental would we uh
do some additional generosity and making
those decisions together rather than
just running this like it's a joint
venture um I think you're going to find
a whole new depth to your relationship
ship I don't think you've got a horrible
marriage uh but I think you could I
think I think you're going to find it
being better when you combine matter of
fact I know from working with millions
of people talking them into this and
it's amazing the number of people that
hate us for telling people to combine
their finances but whatever uh we're
right and you're wrong so you ought to
do it um really I mean it works it
changes your marriage it forces you to
dream together it forces you to carry
the weight together it forces you to
communicate about purchase decisions and
for God's sake where we're going to go
for Christmas this year your mother's
house or my mother's house it has to
it's in the budget we have to talk about
you can't just there's no surprises
there's no side agendas it's like this
Unity thing and uh it creates a Unity a
level of unity that nothing else will do
so hey here's the thing what if you
combined it all and tried it a year and
I was wrong and you absolutely hated it
well you didn't lose any money
just split it back apart what's wrong
with trying it that's what IID do give
it a shot and ask tell him that too just
say hey what if if it doesn't work if we
hate it we can always split it back
apart it's not like a tattoo I mean we
can change it right there's a lot of
stuff we can do here so it's not a
permanent fixture so Ken Coleman good
hour thank you sir thanks for having me
well done well done to the booth people
they did a great job
today good work in there that puts us
our the Ramsey Show in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus hey it's Ken if you like what you
heard in this episode and want to to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsey Baby Steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation again that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started